der brave beamte baraka und das model
bibi zwei welten treffen aufeinander
baraka ist ordnungshüter in saudi
arabien
er sorgt im namen des staates für die
einhaltung der gesetze das model bibi
hingegen bewegt sich in den sozialen
medien und genießt dort freiheiten die
ihr die gesellschaft sonst verwehrt
zensur droht ihr einzig von der
stiefmutter die bibi überwacht romeo und
julia auf arabisch doch der zufall
für die beiden zusammen
der saudische regisseur mahmud abbas
lässt in seinem ersten langspielfilm
tradition auf moderne treffen
er dreht die erste liebeskomödie saudi
arabiens das land in den kinos verboten
sind
und dabei geht der frech und fröhlich
ans werk der gesellschaftlichen realität
entsprechen dann auch die unzähligen
normen und verbote die sich dem glück in
den weg stellen
allein die frage wo und wie soll sich
das bald treffen sie jedenfalls muss zum
ersten date laufen
autofahren ist frauen in saudi arabien
untersagt
es zeugt von mut in diesem land einen
film oder solchen bedingungen zu
realisieren unerschrockenheit ausdauer
und ein feines gespür für das
unausgesprochene zwischen den zeilen
entstanden ist ein leichter und doch
äußerst kritischer fair
umso erstaunlicher dass sich saudi
arabien und durch rang
die liebeskomödie ins oscar rennen zu
schicken das land ohne kinos feiert den
film also immerhin im ausland ist das
ein zeichen für einen liberalen umgang
mit dem medium film
die nominierung von backa racka gibt
grund zur hoffnung
fragt sich nur noch ob es nicht am ende
die oscar academy im freizügigen
kalifornien sein wird die so eindeutige
gesten lieber 10 7